consommez soi-même l'énergie que l'on a
produites sur place c'est le thème de la
quatrième conférence du club climat
énergie une conférence qui se déroule
dans un bâtiment entièrement basé sur la
transition énergétique
vous êtes ici dans un bâtiment de
challenger qui est un exemple même de
l'autoconsommation puisque bien que le
bâtiment date de 1988 il a été
intégralement rénové en début d année
2010 entre 2010 et 2014 pour devenir
maintenant un bâtiment à énergie
positive et qu'il rejette zéro gramme de
co2 l'engagement de saint quentin en
yvelines pour la transition énergétique
permet aux entreprises du territoire de
repenser leur façon de consommer et
trouver des solutions sur le long terme
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à
construire des bâtiments qui ont des
conditions d'exploitation l'énergie qui
sont quasiment neutre c'est pas facile
mais on atteint et on vise demain
atteindre ça pour beaucoup de bâtiments
alors presque une neutralité entre la
dépense d'énergie d'affaires location
nrg donc et le coup on divise par on
vise effectivement de divisé quasiment
par 10 le coût de l'énergie des conseils
sur comment passer à l'autoconsommation
des résultats d'analysés de projet lors
de tables rondes
chaque entreprise expose sa gestion de
la transition énergétique
nous souhaitons présenter aujourd'hui à
la fois les réussites ce qu'on a obtenu
comme résultat les grandes leçons du
projet également les obstacles pour
expliquer que ce n'est pas si facile
aujourd'hui dans le cadre actuel est
bien de pouvoir de porter ce genre
d'offres parce que finalement
aujourd'hui les clients sont intéressés
par la thématique n'ont toujours une
difficulté par rapport aux aspects
économiques étant donné qu'il est encore
difficile de rentabiliser ce genre
d'offre et angie a développé dans cadre
du projet nice m'a révélé une offre
complète intégrant la fois la gestion
locale de l'énergie dans une démarche
d'efficacité énergétique globale
permettant aux clients de contrôler
leurs factures des arguments de poids
pour toutes les entreprises qui sont
sensibles aux enjeux liés à la
protection de l'environnement
l'autoconsommation un projet en voie de
développement pour consommer localement
et devenir consommateurs